welcome to our returning students to our
friends our neighbors from here in New
Haven and a special welcome to the yale
college class of 2014 i'm glad so many
of you were here today this church has
been welcoming Yale students faculty
staff and friends since 1757 though I
think the Welcome was tempered just a
bit by the fact that daily chapel was
required in those days so we want to
welcome you because you've chosen to be
here this morning and we are happy to
see you you made it this is your hour to
relax I know the last couple of days
have been a little insane your parents
have been here they've been moving you
in all kinds of things have been going
on you'd be meeting a thousand strangers
this is an hour to do as little or as
much as you like to just be present here
in the presence of these good people and
of God I'm sure the last couple of days
whether you were on foot or at harvest
whether you're a football player or a
volleyball player whether you came
yesterday or two weeks ago has been
exciting overwhelming and just a little
bit scary who are all these people will
any of them be my friends well my
professors be monsters can I make it
here is always the question and I can
tell you now you will part of my job
here at Yale is to look out at you who
have spent the last 18 years figuring
out how to get into this place and to
say you're done you can step off the
hamster wheel now and delve into
education not credentials not
accomplishments but education in its
depth education in its variety education
not in the things you're good at but in
the things you're bad at education as an
experiment and an opportunity this is
your chance you do not need to fill out
your resume anymore you've reached the
height you can go no further
so take a deep breath and relax you're
among friends you've come to a beautiful
and exciting place where you will learn
more than you ever could have imagined
and then their classes too on top of
that but entering a new church in the
midst of this whole experience is one of
the strangest experiences you'll have in
your life this Sunday morning I remember
I had a student come into chapel one
morning and it was a similar kind of
experience and she was from a strict
Russian Orthodox background and she sort
of wandered into our service and we were
doing this stuff with the drums and the
singing and all this and about nine
minutes into the service she burst into
tears and ran out of the building
because it was not what she was used to
and that may be a little bit of the
feeling you're having today this doesn't
feel like Church should for some it's
your first time away from a home church
for some of you it may be your first
time in a church and I've moved around a
lot in my life as I'm used to walking
into strange churches but even for me
coming into a new church it's a little
overwhelming because there are too many
unfamiliar details the music isn't right
the hymnal I'm used to is not in the
rack the pastor's mannerisms or way of
speaking or just strange he doesn't look
right the hair of the young woman in
front in the fourth row is distracting
me the service feel strange the prayers
aren't where they're supposed to be and
people seem to emotional or not
emotional enough to worm not warm enough
to Christian not Christian enough
compared to what I'm used to and so it
can feel like God isn't here the God is
back home this Sunday God is being
worshipped as God has always been with
my parents and my brothers and my
sisters and those wonderful quirky
familiar people of my home church
because that's where I met God was back
there and where God has been hanging out
so far as I know for the last 18 years
so why should God suddenly pull up
stakes and move to this strange place
and act in these strange ways with all
these unfamiliar
people and unfamiliar songs in this big
old ornate somewhat intimidating
building when I first arrived at college
back in the Paleozoic era being a good
southern methodist I looked up the local
Methodist Church in the local yellow
pages and made my way down there on a
Sunday morning the fact that it was
yellow pages and not the internet tells
you something it was a small white old
New England church unlike my giant
modern stone church back in Texas and
the service was fine it was worshipful
but it just didn't feel right from my
youngest years I knew where God lived
God lived somewhere about 10 feet above
the altar in western hills united
methodist church somewhere between the
author and the stained glass windows
that was God's home God was in the songs
we knew by heart God was in the my
memories of playing the tuba on the roof
of the church on Christmas Eve in my
memorized memories of terrorizing
certain Sunday School teachers and in
memories of the little white bread pill
we got for communion and the little
plastic cup of grape juice given as we
knelt at the altar that was the way God
worked and this was not right since that
move I've relocated about 10 times to
different churches around the world and
every time I entered a new church I had
the same feeling that God was not here
God was somewhere else God was back with
the people I knew and loved and I was
here with strangers fumbling in the
strange worship service feeling only
God's absence but in each place that
first Sunday passed into a second Sunday
and a third and a fourth and the strange
very quickly became familiar and
suddenly people knew my name and I'd
signed up to read or assure and without
understanding how and without even
noticing God somehow packed up from a
thousand miles away and moved here
because we know that God is everywhere
and when you packed up your u-haul last
week with your parents or your suitcases
from wherever you flew from and came
here of course God was there standing at
the curb of your hometown waving goodbye
as the u-haul pulled out and perhaps
letting a tear fall down God's cheek as
you pulled away but when the u-haul
turned off i-95 and pulled in God was
standing at the gate here also and
waiting for you here of course it will
take a few weeks get over the shock and
allow your eyes to begin to see God here
but God is all around you in the
kindness of strangers in the beauty of
this place in the excitement and newness
of it all there is God but still it is
Yael and those four little white letters
on that blue field you know them very
well by now they can be a little scary
there's so many traditions and mysteries
here at Yale so many auditions and tests
that you can begin to wonder where is my
place in all of this does anyone care
about me or just my singing voice just
my debating skills just my athletic
prowess just my brain in our gospel took
message from st. Luke today Jesus is
invited to a dinner party it's a strange
lection for welcoming Sunday but it fits
if we listen to what Jesus is saying
he's invited to this dinner party but
he's not entirely sure the hosts really
want him there as a friend or whether
this is a test of some kind and as the
party gets going Jesus starts telling
rather confusing stories about how one
should act at a party and he advises
echoing the proverb which Brent read
that when you go to a party you should
take the worst seat in the house sounds
right dinner party you're just coming in
the back door you want to take the worse
to see
you
Oh Stefan there you are oh there you are
you shouldn't be back here come on up
come on up you should be up here oh yeah
you want to be right in the action of
things here we go there we go there you
go oh no no you're much too important
let's see if there's a place for you
could you move why don't you just sit
right here there we go wonderful to have
you just stay right there that's what
Jesus did because he said if you take
the worst seat there's a chance that the
host will bring you up and call you up
to a much better place and it's a much
wiser choice than sitting up front oh no
and then having the host push you aside
for someone that's much more important
that's very embarrassing and this
practical wisdom seems to make a little
sense but what does st. Luke want us to
conclude from it that we should act
humble so that we can get a better spot
that seems to be the message of the
story but that doesn't sound like Jesus
at all I think what Jesus is doing here
is not saying pretend to be humble so
that you might get lifted up or avoid
embarrassment at best but I think Jesus
is making fun of us here I think he's
making fun of those guests at the dinner
party he's not so much giving social
advice which we know was never Jesus as
strong suit right Jesus was not the
perfect party animal he was not a social
climber he was not good at this so we
don't go to him for social advice but
rather he's hinting about how pointless
it is to worry about where you're seated
at all and he goes on to push not only
the guests at the party but the hosts
and sounding again like the book of
Proverbs he says if you're giving a
party don't invite the beautiful or the
rich or the powerful because they'll
simply invite you to their parties and
you'll have gained nothing at all you
won't be any holier than you were to
start with but instead go out and invite
the homeless and the outcast in the sick
because they cannot invite you to any
parties and you will gain in holiness
but again it's a very strange story
Jesus i think is poking fun at us again
because who hosts a party in order to be
holy that's usually not people's first
intent is to gain holiness by hosting a
party the whole point of a party is to
get ahead socially but Jesus is asking
is getting ahead socially what really
matters so I think there might be a
message here not just for new students
but for all of us as we begin a new year
because someone who loved me feasts and
marriage banquets and people as much as
Jesus did was giving us a special
message he should just be sitting back
and enjoying the party he want but he
wants some how to make us ask ourselves
questions and perhaps there's something
more at stake here for Jesus than just
social triumph or social disaster
perhaps he's not even really talking to
the hosts or the guests but rather to us
and his question is not just to the new
students but to everyone why do you care
so much what other people think about
you I'm as guilty as anyone why are you
always striving why are you always
trying to clamber your way up the social
ladder why do you want to sit at the
table with the people who seem to have
it all and suddenly the story is no
longer about being new but it's about
why we lead the lives we lead college
president I works for once said there
were two ideas of the purpose of higher
education the first is that higher
education is about figuring out the
rules of society and then using them to
get ahead it's credential the second is
that higher education is about asking
who made up these rules and are they
right as followers of Jesus Christ in
the midst of one of the most powerful
traditional institutions in America I'm
afraid our calling is not to worry about
how to get invited to the most
prestigious tables but to ask who
decided these were prestigious
who's telling me why I should want this
and what about the people who aren't
welcome at the door yay glee one of our
student deacons always reminds me that
one of the purposes of our church is to
lend a moral context to the rest of the
euro Yale journey to your educational
and social journey but to keep you
grounded in a moral context because
Jesus especially in the Gospel of Luke
keeps telling us over and over and over
again that we taste the kingdom of God
when we sit down not with the rich and
the powerful but with the rejected and
the outcast now you're probably asking
yourself why is he telling me this on my
first Sunday can't I just celebrate for
a few minutes before we get too heavily
into conscience or analysis I ended up
at the top of the heat finally I got
into Yale everything is wonderful can't
I just enjoyed the possibility of
hobnobbing with the rich and famous for
a little while of course you can and you
should you are amazing you are
unbeatable you are beautiful you are
talented you are brilliant you were
stupendous you are beyond superlatives
but still in this Chapel we are not the
sum of our accomplishments we live by
different set of rules rules that most
of the people in this world think are
crazy we follow a wandering Jewish
teacher from 2,000 years ago who taught
us that a different set of rules was
breaking into history right now and that
this new set of rules would not only
turn the world on its head and establish
justice and peace but that it would
reconcile each of us to God people here
at Yale talk about how most of us have
some kind of imposter complex the
sinking feeling that you really aren't
supposed to be here that everyone else
is prettier whittier smarter and just
around a much much better person at any
moment now they'll figure me out and
toss me out on my ear they'll find a
younger skinnier chaplain
with more hair and better jokes they
made a mistake when they let me in and
what's more surprising I think for all
of us is that the more students I know
well what's surprising is that even the
most objectively beautiful smart
accomplished the one students were at
the very top of the heap even they feel
this way even they feel that they're
somehow on the outside looking in what
this place offers you on a Sunday and
these good people is a center when
everything else is in turbulence when
everything else is in uproar when things
are not going the way you hoped this is
a place we hope where you find your
Center in Jesus Christ so that you know
when you're in trouble when you need a
friend when everything else has gone
wrong that this is the place you can
come so my message for you as you begin
this remarkable journey is to always
remember the God who made you by hand
who will be with you even when the
unthinkable happens who wants you to
have joy in your heart and your soul not
just in your head and who really doesn't
care what acapella group you're in I'm
sorry I hope you'll let Callista and
maybe your pastors while you're here and
let the wonderful people of this church
be a family to you and that you'll join
us as we seek and struggle to be
Christ's body for this place our
scripture today that Marichal read says
jesus christ is the same yesterday today
and tomorrow and so may it be for each
of us Jesus Christ is the same before
Yale at Yale after Yale Christ keeps us
always moving forward in faith welcome
it's great to have you asked us for
anything you want we're here to help you
amen